just to go back to trudeau though um
who is a duplicitous ken doll
which i'm i that's great that's that
seems to be true yes
um
from his self-imposed quarantine he
managed to tweet from you know what must
be you know it must be very hard for him
um
zach if you will show this to all of the
parents out there this is from yesterday
to all the parents out there if you
haven't gotten your kids vaccinated yet
please get that taken care of as soon as
you can it's the best thing you can do
to keep them and those around them safe
right now hashtag kids vaccines day
kids vaccines day what the hell is that
well
um
hopefully prime minister trudeau has
followed that up with if you have
questions about the vaccines that's okay
science up first child health can at
sandbox canada are hosting a town hall
tonight that was last night sorry guys
you missed it
where you can ask your questions there
and get the best available evidence from
canadian healthcare leaders here's the
details so here we go
this is national kids and vaccines day
that was yesterday we all missed it now
this is only in canada
you know our our people didn't think of
it um
wait wait wait wait they put kids and
vaccines day on holocaust remembrance
day
that was yesterday wow
was was that
january 27th was holocaust foreign yes
um
so okay just for those listening the
coven 19 vaccines approved in canada are
safe effective and save lives let's move
the needle pun intended and promote
vaccine confidence to promote the
largest unvaccinated cohort of people in
canada kids
so
so as has been pointed out
over and over and over again as is
actually clear in the crap data that we
are receiving this much is actually
completely clear
the age stratification risk for this
disease
is so incredible usually you would see a
u-curve right usually for many diseases
you would see old people and young
people at greater risk
and
uh and
young adults and middle-aged adults at
relatively low risk not so for covid not
so for covid the older you are the more
at risk you are from kovet
what is
a greater risk for the young in this
case especially young men and boys is
these vaccines
and not only is the risk greater but the
loss is greater the loss is greater for
kids to the extent that they scar their
hearts with myocarditis you're talking
about living an entire life with a
scarred heart rather than living the
last few decades of life if you were you
know right
50
the idea of a one-size-fits-all
mandate for everyone regardless of past
exposure regardless of actual risk due
to age regardless of actual risk to
comorbidities
of you know of both the disease and from
the vaccines
is again
anti-science
this is
not policy based in scientific thinking
it can't be because static conclusions
don't fit with the complexity of a
global pandemic they don't it is
anti-scientific it is not even
unscientific it is anti-scientific to be
recommending this especially in light of
the fact that to the extent that the
vaccines work at all
and they prevent kids from getting
omicron they may be exposing those same
kids to future variants which may not be
so
so safe for healthy kids yes and
the idea that we would expose kids to
future risk and then put those kids as
they grow up in the bind of having to
accept whatever
whatever remedy is being provided by big
pharma at that time rather than allow
them to acquire immunity which they can
do cheaply now which you know i wish
that wasn't the mechanism but it's far
better than what they're being provided
the idea
that we are going to
basically you know
use triumphalist language and tell
people you're protecting your child
protecting to find protecting from what
right yeah from what are you protecting
them you're you're vaccinating them with
an experimental yes experimental remedy
that is dangerous to them you you are
doing that to protect them from
something that could be
as mild as a cold or milder
right and you're not telling them
to supplement their vitamin d because
they live too far north to make it in
the winter and they're almost certainly
deficient right what kind of upside down
world are we living in
[Music]